[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in this video going to be discussing one
of the most loved and hated characters
in the series
draco malfoy draco malfoy was a british
pureblood wizard born in the year 1980
the son of narcissa malfoy and death
eater lucius malfoy
draco started at hogwarts in the same
year as harry ron
hermione and many of the other
characters that were also familiar with
right from the beginning we get a sense
that draco is the archetypal bully
jk rowling describes draco's character
as follows everybody recognizes straight
because everybody has known somebody
like him
such people's belief in their own
superiority can be infuriating
laughable or intimidating depending on
the circumstances in which one meets
them
draco succeeds in provoking all these
feelings in harry ron and hermione
at one point in time or another draco's
character development throughout the
films is quite extraordinary as he goes
from playful school bully to a confused
young man that is slowly driven to the
dark side
draco of course hails from the malfoy
family a family of elitist purebloods
that look down upon anyone that comes
from muggle descent
his father lucius was a two-faced death
eater that worked for the ministry of
magic but still secretly served the dark
lord
i feel sorry for draco's character
because he became the product of his
environment
he was constantly surrounded by dark
evil wizards and as a young and
impressionable young man
it was almost as if he had no choice but
to go down a dark path
the catalyst that really set him off was
when his father was imprisoned after the
battle of the department of mysteries
a battle that effectively served as the
catalyst and first major conflict
of the second wizarding war with the
imprisonment of his father draco felt
the pressure and knew that he would need
to step up to the plate
and fulfill the malfoy name even if deep
down that wasn't something that he
wanted to do
so to answer the question what would
draco malfoy see in the mirror of erised
i think that it would be most
appropriate to first determine which
draco we are addressing
are we addressing the young and
impressionable draco malfoy who had his
whole life ahead of him and had not yet
entirely succumbed to dark forces
or are we addressing the confused young
man that felt the pressure of the dark
forces surrounding him
in case you've forgotten how the mirror
avera said works it's a magical mirror
that shows us the deepest most desperate
desires of our hearts
this is reflected in the mirror's name
no pun intended as eris had flipped
around
reads as desire the mirror itself was
made sometime before the end of the 19th
century
and is located in the room of
requirement in hogwarts
engraved on the mirror are the words
erased straw eru oit ub kafu oit on
wassi which backwards reads as i show
not your face but your heart's desire
if we were to look at draco malfoy in
the time span of first to fourth year
when he still showed a fair bit of
innocence
i think that we'd see a young man that
just sought validation attention
and respect he was the leader of his
clique of slytherins
and quite popular in his own house but
was always secretly envious of the
attention that harry received
from the student body as a whole
additionally harry would frequently best
draco in things like jules and quidditch
which got in the way of his perception
that he was the best he was
the guy draco wanted to be adored by all
and wanted everyone to have the
perception that he was the best young
wizard around
additionally he desperately wanted his
parents to be proud of him and this was
part of the reason that he always wanted
to be
the best because he knew that it was
what his father wanted so i think that
if he were to have looked into the
mirror during this time frame he would
have seen himself
in his quidditch robes surrounded by the
student body cheering on his success
his parents would be in the stands
cheering and clapping for their son
dumbledore would be smiling and the
scorecard would read slytherin
150 gryffindor zero if we were to look
at draco malfoy in the time span of
fifth year to near
the end of the battle of hogwarts we
would see a very different draco
his priorities had changed and things
had gotten much more severe
his father was imprisoned the playful
pranks that he played on harry
were no longer quite so innocent and the
presence of the dark lord was looming
the pressure was on draco to pick up the
slack for the malfoy family
and he was tasked with the burden of
killing hogwarts headmaster
albus dumbledore the same had master
that he had known since he was just a
small boy
at this point in time draco felt more
pressure than ever he was continuously
pulled toward the darkness
by the people that he associated himself
with but really he was not evil
his internal conflict was all that he
could focus on and he had a hard time
coming to terms with his own identity
was he a malfoy destined to advocate
pure blood supremacy and follow the dark
lord
was he just like everyone else as
draco's internal struggle intensified
he missed classes stopped attending
quidditch practice and did not fulfill
any of his duties as a prefect
these were all things that he would
previously enjoy and it became apparent
that the pressure was affecting him by
the end of the wizarding war
draco's life is in shambles the dark
side that he had chosen
had proved unsuccessful and his family
were probably more ashamed than ever
i think that if he were to have looked
in the mirror at this point he would
have just seen himself
his mother and his father all living a
normal life as they had done before
there would have been no resurgence of
the dark lord and his father would have
left his life as a death eater behind
him
they would have all been happy and
healthy and their family's reputation
would be in good standing
most importantly there would no longer
be any pressure on him to follow dark
pursuits
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think what do you think draco would
see
in the mirror of erised let me know down
in the comment section below
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you